séance est ouverte monsieur le ministre
mes chers
collègues vous pouvez vous
asseoir
je je salue si vous
permettez c'est la rentré je sais bien
mais bon un petit peu de silence s'il
vous plaît je salue les six plus jeunes
sénateurs présent qui rempliront lors de
cette séance les fonctions de secrétaire
d'âge et les invite à siéger à mes côté
au bureau alors je les appelle madame
Mathilde Olivier sénatrice sénatrice
représentante les Français établis hors
de
[Applaudissements]
France Rémy Cardon sénateur de la
Somme
c'est déjà un
ancien Alexandre ouille sénateur de
[Applaudissements]
loise monsieur Sébastien Fanen sénateur
de la
[Applaudissements]
Manche monsieur Josua auchard sénateur
du
[Applaudissements]
Nord et Madame audre bellim sénatrice de
la
[Applaudissements]
Réunion en application de l'article 28
de la Constitution la session ordinaire
2023-2024 est
ouverte alors j'ai reçu la communication
de la liste des sénateurs programmé élu
le 24 septembre 2023 et acte est donné
de cette
communication
alors si vous permettez avant de
procéder à ce que vous attendez tous
c'est-à-dire l'élection du
président monsieur le ministre mes chers
collègues c'est la seconde fois que j'ai
l'honneur de présider cette séance au
privilège de
l'âge et à ce titre je voudrais vous
livrer une
recette je n'ai jamais été autant
médiatisé depuis que je suis réélu à
l'âge de 84
ans d'autant plus que ma fille nouvelle
élue siège aussi parmi nous al leors
avis aux
amateurs plus
sérieusement mes premiers mots sont pour
présenter mes sincères et chaleureuses
félicitations à l'ensemble des
sénatrices et sénateurs nouvellement
élus ou réélu dimanche dernier et je
leur souhaite évidemment la bienvenue au
sein de notre assemblée
j'ai aussi une pensée
particulière pour toutes celles et tous
ceux qui ne siégeront plus parmi nous
soit parce qu'ils n'ont pas souhaité se
représenter soit parce qu'ils n'ont pas
été reconduits qu' soi remerciés de
leurs actions constructif dans tous les
domaines de la qualité de leur travail
et de la participation à nos
débats le Sénat a ses règles ses codes
son ambiance plus fautrait que celle de
l'Assemblée nationale surtout en ce
moment un ancien et célèbre sénateur et
je pense que certains vont le
reconnaître disait à l'Assemblée
nationale on tue avec le poignard au
Sénat on empoisonne avec le
sourire loin des turbulences du Palais
Bourbon souvent soumis au souousbressau
de l'actualité la Haute Assemblée reste
un espace de stabilité dans nos
institutions où l'on sait que la
politique c'est l'art du
compromis mais le Sénat ne vit pas moins
intensément le débat il a toujours su
faire place à la confrontation et au
respect des idées il est garant de notre
démocratie et il fabrique la loi souvent
de façon plus subtile et peut-être plus
réaliste nous sommes avant tout des
parlementaires et dans un régime qui l'
de moins en moins le contrôle de
l'action du gouvernement
et l'évaluation des politiques publiques
sont plus que jamais
essentielles alors je reste
personnellement un partisan acharné du
dialogue constructif de la
cononstruction des lois avec le
gouvernement et l'Assemblée nationale
bien sûr avec des députés qui
malheureusement ne comprennent pas
toujours que ce qui leur reste de
pouvoir se trouve dans le dialogue avec
nous c'est une manière de rendre le
bicamérisme
vivant car il est un antidote à toute
forme de populisme et d'extrémisme ces
mots qui menacent la cohésion sociale et
la construction européenne les
ingénieurs de ce chaos sont à l'œuvre il
est urgent d'enrayer la machine à
détruire la
démocratie et face à cette
menace il nous faut me semble-t-il
mobiliser en priorité les élus locaux
ceux qui sont en première ligne ce que
j'appellerai l'armée de la République du
quotidien qui se sent parfois incompris
ou délaissés et dont nous sommes ici les
représentants le rôle du Sénat est donc
plus que jamais en tant qu'assemblée des
territoires de relever les défis qui
nous
entourent la fracture territoriale la
perte d'autonomie fiscale l' ement des
normes la transition énergétique la
sécurité et j'en
passe je ne doute pas que la somme des
talents et de compétences d'expérience
dans not dans notre assemblée
renouvelée apportera beaucoup à la
fabrication de la loi et à la résolution
de ces enjeux majeurs avec le courage de
la nuance dont parlait Albert Camu bien
loin des facilités de l'outrance voilà
mes chers collègues
l'heure n'est plus à la mise en cause de
l'existence du Sénat dieu merci bien au
contraire tout le monde aujourd'hui a
pris conscience que lorsqu'une assemblée
boîte ou vacille l'autre apporte
l'équilibre indispensable bon
fonctionnement de nos institutions alors
par gros temps faut de bon marin et vous
en êtes mes chers collègues et un bon
capitaine nous l'avons alors donc sans
tarder passons à l'élection du capitaine
oh pardon du président
[Applaudissements]
merci merci beaucoup l'ordre du jour
appelle le scrutin pour l'élection du
président du Sénat j'ai été saisi de
quatre
candidatures madame Cécile cuquierman
monsieur Guillaume
Gontard Monsieur Patrick canner et
Monsieur Gérard
Larcher alors conformément à l'article 2
du règlement cette élection a lieu au
scrutin secret à la
tribune et pour être élu au premier tour
un candidat à la présidence du Sénat
doit recueillir la majorité absolue des
suffrage exprimé ça ne vous surprend pas
si la majorité absolue des suffrages
exprimés pas été acquise au 1er et au 2e
tour de scrutin au 3e tour la majorité
relative suffit je vous rappelle que les
délégations de vote sont admises mais
que le délai limite pour la transmission
de ces délégations était désormais fixé
à 13h et c'est expiré la liste des
délégations de vote a été régulièrement
adressée à la
présidence les sénateurs qui ont reçu
une délégation pourront venir voter à
l'appel soit de leur nom soit de celui
du délégant
j'invite donc nos deux plus jeunes
secrétaires d'âge madame Mathilde
Olivier et Monsieur Rémy Cardon à
superviser ces opérations de
vote alors mes chers collègues des
buletins de vote et une enveloppe ont
été déposé sur votre pupitre vous serez
invité à voter à la
tribune en remettant votre enveloppe au
à la plus jeune secrétaire d'âge qui la
placera même dans
l'urne je rappelle que vous pourrez
voter à l'appel de votre nom ou de celui
de votre
délégant des idoloir ont été installés
pour ceux qui le souhaitent l'un au pied
de la tribune et l'autre en salle des
conférences il va être procéd donc à
l'appel nominal de de nos collègues en
en appelant tout d'abord ce dont le nom
commence par une lettre tirée au sort
il sera ensuite procédé à un nouvel
appel des sénateurs qui n'auront pas
répondu au premier appel de leur nom je
vais tirer au sort cette lettre par
laquelle nous commencerons
ah ça fait des heureux
et d'autrre
moins
voilà c'est vraiment une assemblée
dissipée que nous avons aujourd'hui ça
doit être le
temps le scrutin pour l'élection du
président du Sénat est ouvert sera clos
évidemment quelques instants après
l'appel nominal messieurs les huissiers
veuillez commencer l'appel s'il vous
plaît
lettre lettre lettre
U monsieur
usena lettre V madame Valente
Leir
monsieur
valallette monsieur van
lorenberg madame varayas
il a vé
Président Monsieur vessous
fort madame
vantalon
madame
verien madame
vermeiller
monsieur
verselen monsieur
Vial monsieur
Vogel Louis
Monsieur Jean-Pierre
Vogel madame Mélanie
Vogel lettre
W monsieur
waterbled
monsieur
Weber lettre
X monsieur rou
lettre
Z monsieur
Zian
lettre
A madame
hliman monsieur
Alizard Monsieur
anglar Madame
Antoine madame
apoursopoli Monsieur
Arnaud
madame
Artigalas lettre
B monsieur by
Jérémi monsieur bati
Jean monsieur
Bansard monsieur
Baros monsieur
bas monsieur
Bazin madame
bellim monsieur
bin madame
burau madame
belrti
monsieur ben
roche
madame
Berté monsieur
bilac madame
billon monsieur
bis iltait pas passé encore
monsieur Étienne
blanc monsieur grégoryi
blanc
monsieur Jean-Baptiste
blanc madame blatrix
conttin monsieur monsie
blun monsieur
bet madame beofanti
d'sa Monsieur
Bonhomme monsieur
bonau
monsieur bonne
carère madame
Bonnefoi monsieur bonus
madame borchau
Fontain monsieur
Bouade monsieur
boucher
monsieur
Boulou madame
Bourcier
monsieur
Bourgis Monsieur Jean-Marc
Boyer Madame Valérie
Boyer madame
briquet
monsieur
Brisson monsieur
brossa madame
Brossel
madame
Brulin monsieur
bruyenne monsieur
buffet monsieur
bu
monsieur
Burgoa monsieur
Buval lettre C monsieur
Cabanel monsieur
CADC monsieur
cadi
monsieur
Cambier monsieur
Cambon madame
Canales
madame
canailler monsieur
canevette monsieur capo
Canellas monsieur
Capu
monsieur
Cardon madame
Carlotti madame
carer
madame carer
g monsieur
Casabon madame
casbonne monsieur
chayou
madame
chinarcher monsieur
chaise monsieur
chanrel
monsieur
Chassin monsieur
Châtillon monsieur
Chauvet monsieur chevalier
monsieur
chevrolier madame
deidrac monsieur
sigoloti madame
centu
madame
Conconne madame conoué
Mouret madame Corbière
namazo monsieur
corbisé monsieur
courcial monsieur
Cosic madame Cu
Kerman
monsieur
cuiper lettre
D madame
Danielle monsieur
Dantec madame
Darcos
monsieur
Darnaud monsieur
Daras monsieur
dabé monsieur
dabress monsieur
DEAE
madame de
lâtre Monsieur
delcro Madame de
masse monsieur
demi madame de
scè madame dev
ça
monsieur
deinaz Monsieur
dersin Madame
difolco madame douanau
monsieur
Dosu madame
Drexler monsieur
Dufour madame
Duma
madame
Dumont monsieur
Duplomb monsieur
Durin madame
Duranton
monsieur
Durox lettre
E Monsieur
hblé Madame
Espagnac madame estros Sasson
madame eache
brigau madame
éveren lettre
F monsieur
fagant monsieur
Fargeot monsieur
fav
Monsieur
ferud Madame
Ferré monsieur
fernic monsieur fial
monsieur
fialer monsieur
ficher
madame
Floren monsieur
folot monsieur
foissin monsieur
Frassa
lettre G madame
gaker madame
Garnier madame
Gatel monsieur
Guay
monsieur
Jeunet madame
Gerbeau monsieur
gilet
madame
Girardin monsieur
gold monsieur
Gontard
madame
goselin madame
Goulet madame
gavant monsieur
grand madame gréum
monsieur
gremiller monsieur gros
Périn monsieur
grosvallé
madame
gruni monsieur
Guéret monsieur
Guerini monsieur
guerot
madame
Gul madame
guidez madame
Guillotin monsieur
guol lettre
H madame
haribé madame
av monsieur
et Monsieur
H Monsieur
Hervé madame
Herzog monsieur
Ingré
monsieur
auchochard monsieur
houperère monsieur
Hugonet monsieur
Husson lettre
I monsieur
yacovelli
madame
Humbert lettre
J madame
jacquem madame
Jacques monsieur
jacin monsieur
Jade
Monsieur Jean
saanetas monsieur
jolie Monsieur
jaumier Madame
josande madame
Joseph madame Giselle
Jourda madame Murielle
Jourda monsieur
Joyandet lettre
K monsieur
caner
monsieur
kouci monsieur
Kerne monsieur
kerouche monsieur
califé monsieur
Klinger
monsieur
couok lettre
L madame de La
Gonterie madame de La
provoté monsieur
Lafond monsieur
laelec monsieur
Laménie monsieur
lawedge monsieur
Larcher madame l
sarade monsieur
logier
Monsieur Laurent
Daniel Madame Christine
Lavarde monsieur
legleu madame
lewerou monsieur le
rudulier monsieur Lefèvre
monsieur
delè monsieur le
mooine madame
l'ermite monsieur
Leroi monsieur
Lévi
monsieur
lévrier madame
linceneld madame
Loisier Monsieur
longau Madame
Lopez monsieur
louau Monsieur
lausac Madame
Lubin monsieur
Lurel
lettre
M madame
my madame
met monsieur
maluré monsieur Mandelli
monsieur
Marc madame
dearco madame
Margaté
monsieur
Marie monsieur
Marseille Monsieur
Martin Pascal
madame Pauline
Martin monsieur
massé monsieur
Moré monsieur
mdeviel monsieur
Méen monsieur
méouli monsieur
Menonville madame
Mercier monsieur
merillou monsieur
Michalet
monsieur
Michot madame
micouot monsieur
Millon monsieur
Mison Monsieur Mohamed
swali madame Monier
monsieur
Montauger monsieur de
Montgolfier madame main de
sa monsieur
mouiller madame Müller
Bron lettre
N Mame
nadille madame Nara
couin monsieur
naturel madame
Nedelec monsieur de
Nicola
madame
Noël monsieur
nougin lettre
E madame
Olivier monsieur Omar
wali monsieur Omar
wali
monsieur
wiille monsieur
ououias lettre
P monsieur
Paco madame
pantelle monsieur
panounzi madame Paulie
gagin
monsieur
paridi monsieur
patient monsieur
patria monsieur
Paul monsieur
Paumier
monsieur
pelvin monsieur
pernaau monsieur
pin madame
per
madame
Pétrus madame finera
Orse monsieur
Piednoir monsieur
pilfer monsieur
plat madame
plucher Monsieur
pointerau Madame poné
Monge madame
pouirol madame
prima madame puissa
lettre
R monsieur
rambau monsieur
Rapin monsieur
ravier monsieur
ravier monsieur rénal
monsieur
renal monsieur Rodon
sarazi Monsieur
rechart Madame Renaud
garabédian
monsieur
rotaillot monsieur
Renault madame
Richard madame
Richer monsieur
Ritman
madame
Robert monsieur
Rochette monsieur
refrich monsieur
Roiron
monsieur
rejoint madame
romaniie monsieur
Ros madame
rossignol
monsieur
rou monsieur
Ruel lettre
S madame
SAÉ monsieur
salmon monsieur
Sori monsieur
satarel monsieur
Savin monsieur
Savoldelli madame
Schalk madame
chilinger madame
monsieur
sido madame
Sylvanie monsieur
sol
madame
sologoube monsieur
saumon madame
swiiris monsieur
stion monsieur
Zurek
monsieur
spiner lettre
T monsieur
Tabarot monsieur
teméal
madame
tétoinoui monsieur
Théophile monsieur
tisso
chers collègues le premier appel nominal
est terminé il va être procédé un nouvel
appel madame
plucher c'est
bon tout c'est
tout bon plus personne ne demande à
voter donc le scrutin est clos et
j'invite madame et Messieurs les
secrétaires d'âge à se rendre dans la
salle des conférences pour opérer et
procéder au dépouillement du
scrutin la séance est suspendue
évidemment pendant ces opérations de
dépouillement tout
le